this is russia's destructive siege of
the last remaining ukrainian resistance
in mariopol
under the smoldering ruins of the azo
style steel plant are 200 civilians
believed to be trapped underground with
ukrainian soldiers
officials in keefe say they are making a
new attempt to get them out with the
help from the u.n
currently russian shelling and the
assault on as of style has not stopped
but civilians still need to be taken out
women children many children who are
still there just imagine this hell more
than two months of constant shelling
bombing constant death nearby we expect
an effective regime of silence but we
are doing everything to find a solution
and to save our military
russian tanks are not far away
their allied separatist fighters patrol
the streets
this fighter thinks victory in azerstal
of style
everything is fine we are working we are
fighting sometimes we're not far just a
little left step by step
in moscow soldiers are preparing for
monday's parade to mark victory against
nazi germany during the second world war
but in the war in ukraine president
vladimir putin doesn't have much to
celebrate
the war has isolated his nation and
united its foes
no punishment or sanctions can break the
will of our people of the russian
leadership aimed at defending the
historical truth
the legitimate interests of the russian
federation
and preventing direct threats to our
security being created on our borders
threats to our culture our history
all this is currently at stake
with russian troops now preparing to
take a full control of mario paul it's
not clear when or how this war will come
to an end
priyanka gupta al jazeera